Testament to my officers on wavering a
dedicated machine for justice that David
Carrick has been handed 36 life
sentences today
I'm truly humbled by The Bravery of the
victims each one was prepared to live
their horrendous ordeal face character
in ports I would also like to thank the
crown prosecution team at Thames Shelton
who worked side by side with the
exceptional team of lawyers since
October 2021 building a strong and
compelling case
our investigation does not stop here
however and we've set up a special
reporting portal to allow people to
continue to share information with us
this portal will remain open and details
can be found on the hartfordshire Police
website
I would urge anyone who thinks they've
been a victim of David Carrick to come
forward we still want to hear from you
and we will support you
as a serving police officer David
Carrick has brought shame on the
profession and was not fit to wear the
uniform but I hope that our
determination to get Justice for the
victims in this case we'll go some way
to reassuring the public that nobody is
above the law and we will we will bring
people like David Carrick to Justice
today is about recognizing the
outstanding bravery of the victims it
often takes courage for anyone to come
forward and report a rate but in this
case to overcome the mental and physical
oppression they endured may have felt
insurmountable at times
we've heard the accounts of women who
suffered at carrick's hands
he took away their control their right
to choose their freedom
in some cases both physically and
mentally
we cannot undo the pain and anguish that
they have endured but I hope that they
can take this first step and be building
their lives knowing that he can't harm
them
or any other woman
we are so grateful to every woman who
has come forward and supported this case
with each report that came in we had a
clearer picture of who Carrick was and
what he had done
the similarities between the victim
accounts detailing mental and physical
torment at the hands of the same man
were our case
we would not be where we are today
without you
the victims
taking that step forward and providing
us with a vital evidence needed to
prosecute Carrick
with your help the crown prosecution
service works with the investigation
team at Hertfordshire constabulary to
build such a strong case that Carrick
had no choice but to plead guilty
we know there are victims of other rape
and serious sexual offenses out there
and that many of you may be worried
about being believed or whether you will
ever see Justice dunk we understand
these concerns I want to reassure you
that we are doing everything that we can
to improve how these offenses are
handled and we are determined to seek
Justice Stone for more victims of
violence against women and girls
we hope seeing Carrick a prolific abuser
manipulator and rapist behind bars will
encourage other women to come forward
knowing we will do all we can to hold
personal responsible